♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Here in the U.S.,
the Paris attackers
touched off a ferocious debate
about Syrian refugees.
You might remember,
President Obama had pledged
to accept at least 10,000
over the next year but after
news broke that one of the
attackers may have posed
as a refugee and
entered Europe through Greece
with a fake Syrian passport,
many U.S. officials had
second thoughts.
REPORTER: Thirty-one
governors now oppose,
are refusing or suspending
the resettlement of Syrian
refugees into their states.
Okay, that's pretty extreme but
it's also pretty meaningless
for two reasons.
One, governors don't have the
legal authority to ban refugees.
And two, even if they could,
Syrians can't just walk between
states like anyone else.
The lines on maps are not
crocodile-filled moats.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Presidential candidates also
got involved with this
anti-refugee rhetoric.
Donald Trump, Ben Carson
and Marco Rubio
called for halts
to all Syrian refugees
entering the country.
And others like Ted Cruz and
Jeb Bush argued we could take
some if they were Christian.
If you're wondering how
that would work,
let Jeb Bush explain.
What, you're a Christian,
I mean, you can prove
you're a Christian. It's--
-How?
-I think you can prove it.
I think you can prove it,
I'm pretty sure
you can prove it.
You see, I'll tell you how.
You see...
a Christian has ears that
protrude out from their heads,
whereas non-Christians lack
external ears all together.
You know what? Hold on.
I'm thinking about seals
and sea lions.
I often get them confused...
Forget everything I said about
Christians and Muslims.
I don't know
what I'm talking about.
And it was not just Republicans.
The Democratic mayor of
Roanoke, Virginia, David Bowers
was so terrified of Syrian
refugees, he used
the worst possible historical
example to prove his point.
REPORTER: Mayor
David Bowers wrote:
(REPORTER READING LETTER)
Wow!
Did he not realize that
Japanese internment camps
are one of this nation's
greatest sources of shame?
It's one of the parts of
FDR's legacy
his family would
most like you to forget.
And bear in mind, this is a man
who's own biopic featured
featured a scene of him
getting a hand job
from his distant cousin.
♪ (ROMANTIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Did I have to show you that?
No.
Did I want to?
Absolutely, I did!
But this week's events actually
call to mind a chapter
from FDR's time in office
that is even more shameful
than the saddest and classiest
hand job of all time.
Specifically, when in 1939,
U.S. authorities turned away
a ship containing
more than 900 mostly Jewish
refugees from Germany.
Something American newsrooms
at the time
tried to put a positive spin on.
NARRATOR: Nine hundred-seven
Jewish unfortunates
without a country
permitted to land
in Belgium after five weeks
of suspense afloat.
Through American generosity,
they will find at least
temporary shelter
in France, Holland and England.
Yes. We sent a boat of Jews
back to Europe in 1939.
More than a quarter of them
then died in the war.
So this Thanksgiving, when
your grandmother's complaining
about your new piercing saying
your generation is terrible.
Simply reply, "Okay, Nanna."
"But at least we didn't send
Jews back to Europe in 1939."
Then break off a turkey leg,
drop it like a microphone
and you've just won the dinner.
Dinner over!
Although...
let's be honest here.
Every generation has had
it's own ugly reaction
to refugees.
Whether they are the Irish,
the Vietnamese, the Cubans
or the Haitians.
And those fears have been
broadly unfounded.
In fact, there was only one time
in American history when
the fear of refugees
wiping everyone out
did actually come true.
And we'll all be sitting
around a table
celebrating it on Thursday.
And look, it is absolutely fair.
It's fair to be concerned
about safety in the wake
of these attacks.
And it's fair to wonder
who we're letting in
and what sort of
screening system is in place.
Unfortunately, many
of the people talking about it
this week,
don't seem to have
the first idea
of what we're doing.
Do we know who these people are?
No.
Are they properly vetted?
How do you vet them?
There's no possible way
to vet them.
There's virtually no vetting
'cause there are no databases
in Syria.
There are no government records.
We don't know
who these people are.
Look, it is difficult
to vet people coming out
of a war zone.
But it's not like
we're just letting anyone in.
We are the United States
of America, not Arizona State.
Because for the...
Just for the record here.
Let me walk you through
what our screening process
actually is.
If you're a refugee, first,
you apply through
the United Nations'
High Commissioner for Refugees,
which collects documents and
performs interviews.
Incidentally, less than
one percent
of refugees worldwide
end up being recommended
for resettlement.
But, if you're one of them,
you might be referred
to the state department
to begin the vetting process.
At this point, more information
is collected.
You'll be put through
security screenings by the
National
Counterterrorism Center,
the FBI, and the
Department of Homeland Security.
And if you're a Syrian refugee,
you'll get an additional
layer of screening
called the Syria
in-house review,
which may include
a further check
by a special part of
Homeland Security,
the USCIS Fraud detection,
and National Security directors.
And don't relax yet, 'cause
we've barely even started.
Then, you finally get
an interview with USCIS officers
and you'll also be fingerprinted
so your prints can be run
through the biometric databases
of the FBI, the Department of
Homeland Security,
and the Department of Defense.
And if you make it through
all that, you'll then have
health screenings,
which, let's face it,
may not go too well for you,
'cause you may have
given yourself a stroke
getting through
this process so far.
But if everything
comes back clear,
you'll be enrolled in
Cultural Orientation classes
all while your information
continues to be checked
recurrently against
terrorist databases
to makes sure that
no new information
comes in
that wasn't caught before.
All of that has to happen
before you get near a plane.
This process typically takes
18-24 months
once you've been referred
by the U.N.
to the United States.
This is the most rigorous
vetting anyone has to face
before entering this country.
No terrorist in their right mind
would choose this path
when the visa process
requires far less efforts.
But nevertheless, the House
still voted on Thursday
to add a few more steps.
The house voted 289 to 137 for
tougher screening procedures
requiring the FBI director
to sign off on each
and every refugee.
He signs off...
That is ridiculous!
At this point, why don't we just
include a pie-eating contest,
a spelling bee,
and an evening wear portion.
But the really hard truth here
is no one can promise
that someone dangerous still
might not slip through.
And while that risk should
not be denied,
it also should
not be wildly inflated.
Let me ask this.
If you bought a five-pound
bag of peanuts,
and you knew that
in the five-pound bag of peanuts
there were about 10 peanuts
that were deadly poisonous,
would you feed them
to your kids?
The answer is no.
Yeah, of course it's no.
For starters, you should
give your kids and actual meal,
not a handful of peanuts
because they're human children
not circus elephants.
But second,
we wanted to do
the math on what he just said.
So we bought five pounds
of peanuts and we counted them.
There are about
1,000 nuts in there.
So if 10 of them
are poisoned,
Mike Huckabee
is essentially suggesting
that about one of every 100
refugees is a terrorist.
But in reality, of the more than
784,000 refugees
admitted to the U.S.
since 9/11,
only three have
been arrested for
planning terrorist activities.
None of which, by the way,
resulted in attacks here.
So, the actual known ratio
of arrested terror suspects
to refugees is not one in 100.
It's one in roughly 261,000.
Peanuts themselves
have killed far more people
in the last decade
than terrorist refugees.
Oh, I'll go one step further!
Men named Mike have
killed more people
than terrorist refugees
and I don't see us
rounding all of them up.
And that's kind of the point.
Because as reasonably adults,
we accept tiny amounts of risk
baked into our everyday lives.
We drive cars, despite knowing
around 30,000 of us
die in them each year.
We go swimming, despite the fact
10 people a day
die from drowning.
Twenty Americans every year
are killed by cows.
But no one is saying we should
expel all cows from the country.
We're happy just taking them
out one at a time, thinking,
"Well, we got them before
they got us."
This is what freedom
tastes like.
Any rational person knows
you cannot completely
eliminate risk.
You can only manage it.
And we do it with peanuts
and cars, and swimming,
and hamburgers,
and men named Mike.
'Cause we rightly think that
they're worth the risk.
And I would argue for the
tremendous good we could do,
and the low-level
of risk involved,
refugees are worth it, too.
And you may disagree,
but it is worth noting
that as we devise new ways
to close our doors this week,
France, which has
just suffered a terror attack
and has far less ability
to police its borders,
did this.
REPORTER: French President
Francoise Hollande says
France will still welcome
refugees into the country
despite the Paris massacre.
Speaking at a gathering of the
nation's mayors,
he said France
will keep its commitment
to take in 30,000 refugees
over the next two years.
Hollande added that France will
remain a country of freedom.
Yeah, because they think it's
worth the risk!
And it's frankly not ideal.
Francoise Hollande,
a man who broke up with his
partner of 30 years,
in order to shack up
with a lover
who looks exactly like her,
just 10 years younger
Only to quickly leave that lover
for another lover,
who looks
exactly like the second lover,
just 10 years younger again.
That man is currently
functioning as an effective
moral compass
for your politicians.